サッブパパッサアカラナン クシャラッサウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダタナン エタングブッダンササナナン
では よろしくお願いします
これから今日のテーマについて話したいと思います
あのブッダの教えを勉強するときは
どうしてもこの 我々の知識ではレベルがね
いくらか上がらないといけないんですね
そのためのブッダの話なんですね
我々 本とか読んだりはしますけど
すでにある知識に何か加えるだけの話なんですね
何か成長しましたっていうことはなかなかないんです
ですから ブッダの話は
まあそんなに気持ちよくて
元気で なんか音楽聴いてるような雰囲気でもう聞くことは難しいかもしれません
何か学ばなくてはいけない
いまだかつて知らなかった何かをね
新たに学ばなくてはいけないというふうなことにもどうしてもなります
学校の授業のような感じになりますね
学校の授業っていうのは
子供たちが 生徒たちが知ってることを言ってるわけじゃないんですね
知らないことを言ってるんですね
だからみんな嫌な顔をするんですけど
仕方がありませんね 学ばなくちゃいけない
それで若者が勉強して進んでいくんです
先生言うことはわからない
聞きたくないということになっちゃうと
勉強しないままで終わりますね
人生は だから どちらかというと
仏教も教育の世界で 人間には知らないことを次から次へと教えてあげてはいるんです
はい 今日のテーマは聖なるものの証明ということで
えーと 難しくなるか簡単になるかっていうことは
ちょっと私もよくわからないんですけど
この聖ということはね
聖なるという言葉はね
特に仏教はものすごく使うんです
で 世間のすべてのものをまとめて俗
俗っていうことに俗世間の俗ですね
ブッダがブッダのみが語るものは
この聖なる世界っていう風に分けているんですね
だから聖なるっていう風に日本語するんだけど
まああのパーリ語では
まあそういう風な なんとなくちょっと排他的
差別的な意味もないんですけど
アリアという言葉ですね
アリアの世界 アーリアの世界
アーリアっていうのは
この英語ではノーブル
優れているという意味なんですね
その場合も一般の人とはちょっと違うということになりますけど
まあだからみんなにこのあなた方は頑張ってね
聖なる世界というか ノーベル
優れた世界を入ってくださいということになります
で 他の宗教でも言ってる
この神を信じる人々は優れていて
信じていない人々はろくでもない人間だというふうな感じじゃないんですね
ネチェレンを信仰するならば
その人だけ成仏できて
他の人たちは地獄に落ちますよというね
こういうのはいい加減で
そういうことではなくて
ちゃんとこの理由をつけて持っていくんですね
例えばどこかでね 会社かどこかにね
入ろうとすると資格を聞くんですね
例えばある会社でね あんた工学部を出ているのかと
うちの会社はこの工学部をね
出て卒業している若者を雇いますよと言ったら
差別ではないんですね
で そういう能力は必要だからそう言っているだけでね
ですから この能力の問題であって
ただ信仰することの問題じゃないんですね
だからアーリアの世界
優れた世界 そうでない世界っていうのは
能力の世界なんですね
だから若者に工学部を出るなよって誰も禁止していないんだから
資格取ればいいんですよ
そういうことで このその内容をこれから勉強していきましょう
そこで この知識に頼る世界は俗世間です
と言っても 知識に頼らないでも生きる人間いくらでもいますから
それはもっとレベルが低いんですね
普通な文化人だったら結構知識もありましてね
知識に頼って生きているんですね
だから知識が大事にするんですね
で 世界でも知識人をよく認めてくれるんですね
だからどちらかというと
世の中 なんか金があればいいやと言ってるわりに
金よりもすごい抜群の知識があったら
その人のことが金持ちよりも褒め称えられるんですよ
社会は認めるんです 現実はそうなんです
だから金いくらかっていうことは
我々そう思っているだけで
あの人はすごい金持ちだから褒め称えましょうということはあまりないんです
すごい知識人だったら
その人を呼んで講演を聞いて学んだり
いろいろするんですね
いや 世の中に何か問題が起きたら
じゃあ金持ちに聞こうっていうことはないでしょ
どっちでもないんです
今は社会に問題が起きていますから
世界の億万長者たちにどうすればいいかと聞きましょう
全然ないんです ノーベル賞を取った人々やら
ものすごい優秀な大学の教授たちやら
そういう専門ですね 専門家に意見を聞くんですね
だから文化世界っていうのは
知識人を大事にする ということは
世界は知識に頼って生きているんですね
お釈迦様がこの知識に頼って生きている世界は俗世間であると言われる立場なんです
智慧の世界は聖なる いわゆる出世間の世界なんです
だから世間と世間から飛び上がった世界
出世間 それは智慧に智慧の世界
あの智慧に頼る世界ではないんです
これ 微妙な言葉のニュアンスも覚えた方がいいんですね
我々は知識に頼って生きているんです
それで ブッダの世界は
智慧の世界であって 頼るという言葉がないんです
なんか同じこっちゃと思うでしょうね
本当にすごい違うんです
これは説明は避けた方がいいと思います
いわゆる存在そのものの問題に乗り越えているんですね
生きていきたい 生きていきたいと思うならば
何かに頼らなくてはいけないんですね
例えば 今 私たちみんな呼吸に頼っているでしょ
呼吸がなかったら生きていられないんですね
だから生きていきたければ呼吸しなくちゃいけないということで
生きることは何かに頼って生きているんです
何か杖が必要なんです
だから俗世間は生きる世界なんですね
だから何かにね ご飯やらお金やら服やら
いろんなものに頼って
物質に頼っていなくちゃいけないんですね
物質に頼ることは誰だってやってますから
文化人的な理性のある世界では
まあ物質は必要なんですけど
それを置いておいて それより知識っていうものにも頼っているんですね
ですから ブッダの世界では智慧がある世界
要するに何にも頼らない世界なんです
知識って何なのかというと
五感から入るデータを頭で合成して概念を作るんですね
智慧とは あるのままの真理を発見することです
そうやって区別を理解しておきましょう
そこで知識っていうのは
目 耳 鼻からいろんなデータが入る
そのデータを頭の中でいろいろからくりして合成する
合成して概念を作るんですね
それに知識というんです
だから最初から知識っていうのは怪しいものなんです
各人が自分の認識持ってますけど
データどのように合成するのかっていうことは
各個人の世界なんです
バラのお花を見て美しく見ようか
つまらないと見ようかっていうことは
その個人の世界なんですね
あなた方は必ずバラの花が美しいものであると見なさいよというふうに命じることはできません
何か食べ物を出して 必ずこれは最高に美味しいと思いなさいと
これは無理ですね 食べるものを食べても
各個人が最高に美味しいか
最高に不味いか どうったことはないかとね
まあまあ美味しいかと
ちょっとまずっぽいなとか
いろんな判断するのは
その個人の世界なんですね
なんとなく個人が自由なような感じますね
これ 自由かどうか分からないんだから
私は使っているのは主観で勝手という言葉なんです
個人とは主観的に生きているもので
勝手に生きているもの
自由とは言わないんです
私はその言葉は避けるんです
本当は自由はないんですね
生きている間は 輪廻転生する間は自由はないんです
だから仏教はこれは明確に束縛という生命は束縛されている
煩悩にはもう一つ動機
愚痴もあってね それは束縛なんですね
束縛されている生命が自由自由というのはおかしい話なんですね
自由はないが 我々は勝手なんですね
食べたものは美味しいか
まあものすごい美味しいか
ものすごいまずいか まあ美味しいか
まあある程度で美味しいかとかね
なんとなくまずっぽいとか
どんな判断するのもその人の勝手であって
自由ということはないんです
はい それで五感から入るデータは自分の勝手に合成して概念作るんだから
その概念が知識ですからね
その知識に頼って生きているんだから
結構トラブルのある世界なんですね
それで智慧の世界って何なのかというと
ありのままなんでしょうかと
私に見えるということではなくて
例えばバラの花を見た瞬間で
ああ 綺麗と感じたとしましょう
本当にそうなのか 実際何が起きてるのか
と この私の目の前にある対象と目の間のコミュニケーションで何が起きているのかということを調べて
真理を発見する それが智慧の世界
それで知識についてちょっと喋りすぎましたけど
確かなものではありませんね
知識は だって私の五感で自分の勝手でね
ああ 知ってます 知ってよくわかりましたとやら
そんなこと言ったってもね
他の人は別な理解になるでしょう
だから確かじゃないんですね
例えば私は何かご飯を食べて
あ これすごい美味しいと
と決めても これ確かですかね
他の人は いえ これはちょっとこういう風にした方が良かったんじゃない？とかね
この料理の組み合わせは良くないとかね
いろいろ言うかもしれません
そういうわけで 我々は知識に頼ってますが
それは不確かな世界なんです
知識によって見解を作る
そこで我々は知識が出てくると見解
このなんか哲学者になるんですね
みんな勝手にで生きてるわりに
それぞれみんな自分で世界観
人生観持ってるんですよね
これどう考えても笑わなくちゃ
あなた何を知って人生論を持ってるのかと
世界のことろくにあんまり知らないのに
面白いことは 各人が自分の哲学を持ってるんですよ
あの概念からこの見解を作るんです
この見解がないとなかなか一般人には生きづらいんですよね
だからちょっと考えてみましょうか
知識も頼りにならない
これは勝手で主観の知識で
この知識から見解 哲学を作る
その哲学に基づいて世の中のことをさらに判断したり
行動したりする 自分なりの哲学がなければ
食べるものを食料を選ぶときでも選べなくなっちゃうんです
みんな哲学を持ってるんです
例えば牛肉食べるならば
やっぱり和牛しか食べませんよと
偉そうな哲学を作っていて
こんなオーストラリア
アメリカから輸入する肉はもう食べたくないとかね
という哲学を持ってる人もいる
で まあキャベツ食べるならば
何々産地のものは食べますとかね
うーん だから自分なりの見解がなければ
食料さえ選べなくなっちゃいます
今度の休みどうしましょうか？という疑問が与えられたら
各人がじゃあ私はこうする
私はこうしますと持っているでしょう
やること それは自分の見解から割り出した答えなんです
それですべての人間に見解があるんですよ
これまた似てないんですよ
また勝手なんですね でもそちらで見解の場合はカテゴライジングできます
概念はなかなかカテゴライジングインデクシングはできません
索引を作ることは 見解の場合は
あのインデクシングもカテゴライジングというのはね
いわゆるいろいろグループに分けて
いくらか整理することができます
なぜならば 見解というのはある
基本はみんな同じなんですね
どう生きればいいということで
どうすればいい？私はどうすればいいと
それで私はどうすればいいという場合は
その人はわかってないんだけど
私はどのような生き方をすれば良いのかという疑問に対して
自分なりの哲学を作っているんです
というわけで どんな生命も同じ疑問で出している見解だから
見解はカテゴライズできます
だから仏教では見解はそれなりにもいろいろ分けてはあります
概念のはないんです はい
次に行きましょうか いかなる見解にも反対の意見が出れるんですよ
これがややこしいんです
自分がどんな見解を作って
それに沿って生きてみたっても
世の中 世には必ずアンチテーゼがあるんです
ないはずがないんです
じゃあどうしましょうかと
ある人が私は野菜しか食べませんと見解を作る
それでいろんなくだらない哲学を言うんですよ
動物をかわいそうや 殺さなくちゃ食べんでしょうに
残酷やとか あるいは動物の肉
魚っていうのは毒性が高いやとかね
コレステロールが多くて体に良くないやとかね
いくらでも言えますよ
そんなのは一つも自分の生き方を整理する言葉じゃないんです
それで だからこれで決まった
決定ということにならないんです
理由は言うだけ ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ
その中で私は考えている
いくらかまとめられると人間猿でしょう
猿っていうのはもともと菜食主義やと思っていたんだけど
現代の猿たちは肉 魚食べちゃいますね
すべてではないんだけど
動物食べる肉食べる猿たちもいるんですね
だから私の見解もなんか怪しげなものになってしまったんです
だから私は別に何々主義でもないんだけど
じゃあ菜食主義を正当化できないのかと考えたところで
人間の腸が長いし 肉食食べる動物の腸がすごい短いしね
だからさっさと取れるもの取って
毒をさっと体から出すんですね
で 植物食べる生命が この植物の繊維は硬いんだから
これは溶かしちゃって栄養分取るためには時間がかかるんだから
腸が長いんですね だから腸が長い生命は肉食べちゃうと
もう早く分解するものを食べちゃって
長い間のお腹の中に置いておくと
相当まずいんじゃないかなと
毒まで吸収してしまうのではないかという
まあそんなこと言ったって
あんまり大した理論にはならないんですね
だから肉魚食べてもいいという人も自分なりの理由は言うし
菜食主義がいいという人も自分なりの理由は言うんだけど
私はこのごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ理由をつけるだけで
誰も納得できる結論に達する理論は言えません
よく勉強していくと 世の中
皆様もそれで困っていると思いますよ
自分の見解は必死になって弁解するでしょう
でも相手は反論出すんですね
それで悔しくなっちゃうんですね
悔しい状況で終わるんです
その時 勝るのは凶暴でおしゃべり屋で行儀作法がない
人間で喋る時は 文化人ならそれなりの行儀作法あるでしょうに
それも守らないで 凶暴で一方的に喋る最悪の人間が勝ってしまうんですね
議論が起きたら だからどうにもならない世界なんですね
そこでポイントは 私は菜食主義はいい
私は菜食主義で生きましょうと言った途端
あんた何言うのかと 体には肉
魚やら動物性のものは必要だよっていう見解もある
じゃあどちらが正しい？どちらにもそれなりのなんだらかんだら理由はあるんですよ
一つも決定的な理由は持ってないんです
それだけです それで各個人が自分の見解を持っている
見解を持った時点で世間が反論を持っている
例えば 共産主義がいい経済システムであると一部の人々が言うと
とんでもないやと 資本主義こそがという風に出てくるでしょ
どちらが正しい？知ったことじゃないんです
そんなのは 誰の理論もいい加減で決定的にならないんですね
しかし 人は自分の意見に執着して
その意見が正しいと固執します
そこが問題なんです だからちょっと詳しく喋ってしまいました
今の状況では 皆様にも世界の人間にも見解を持たずいられない状態
結構やばい状態にいるんです
がんになった人は いろいろケモテラピーやら放射治療とかを受けなくちゃいけない
これ両方やばいんです
決して体にいい治療じゃないんです
でも がんになってしまえば仕方がありませんね
やばいと知っているにも関わらず
この治療を受けなくちゃいけないんです
というわけで 人間が見解を作らなきゃ生きていられないという頑然にかかっているんですね
そうすると 見解 問題は見解には反論がある
絶対的反論がある 子供が何か意見を言ったら
母親がえ 違いますよと反対するでしょうね
子供は将来音楽家になりたいなと思ったら
母親がダメです そんなのはと言う可能性あります
なりくはないんだと 競争は厳しいよと
だから工学でも医学でも学びなさいよと
いうふうに 世の中は見解の反対意見がありますね
それで問題は自分の生き方だから
見解っていうのは自分の哲学だから
自分自身の人生論だから
それ執着するんですね
固執するんですね むちゃくちゃなんです
だから面白いことは人間であることまで忘れちゃいますよ
私はこの菜食主義の何人かにね
話したことがあるんだけど
まあ肉魚食べる人々は貶しちゃうわ
バカにするわ 見下しちゃうわ
何ですかね 自分が生命のことをものすごく大事にしているんで
私は あのね あなた人間をバカにしてない？人間も生き物ですけどと聞いたんですね
いえいえ もう動物をいくら愛したっても
人間を愛することはできませんと
残酷だと なん私の肩なんだこれやと
本人が菜食主義を通そうと思ったところで
限界にあまりにも固執しちゃって
限界守ることになっちゃって
命守ることは忘れているんです
もともと命を守るために決めた限界でしょうに
反対になっているんです
だから世の中よく見てください
徹底的に平和運動をやっている人は暴動を起こすんです
火炎瓶投げたり 警察をぶん殴ったり
建物を壊したり あれって平和運動？だからみんなこのやっていることはハチャメチャなんですね
問題はどこにあるかと誰も学んでいないんです
それを限界に固執したところで
このバカが限界を守ることにいくんです
忘れたのは 限界は自分を守るために作ったんです
だから 簡単な例で考えましょう
自分の身を守るためにピストルを買う
買ってください 持ってないんだったら
そこで ピストルを大事にせなくちゃいかんでしょ
これ 大事にするあまりにピストルを守る派になるんですね
ピストルが自分を守るじゃなくて
自分がピストルを守ると
それで家に誰かが泥棒入ったところでピストル取られたら困るということで
これだけ守ると思ったらぶん殴られて同じピストルで殺されて死ぬ可能性もあります
だから世の中政治家がね
この武器を守ることに必死でしょ
それで国民が大変なことになっているんだけど
どうでもいいんです 国民を守るためやと言うんですね
軍事費が上がれば上がるほど
国民は生きていられなくなりますけど
税金が上がって上がって
物価が上がって上がって
国民はどうでもいいんで
アメリカではもうほんのわずかな人々しか治療を受けられないんで
知ったことじゃないんですね
アメリカではみんな教育を受けられないんで
金がなくて 知ったことがないんです
アメリカ国が世界一軍事力を持たなくちゃいけないということで
だからこの限界に固執することで
そういう風にこの相相反する矛盾な生き方が現れているんです
皆様に日本の例を言いますね
ある女性から聞いた話なんですけど
自分が生まれた家はいくらか
60年  80年ぐらいの
何かちょっと歴史のある家で
お母さんがこの家を守ることは大事ですよと
だから お母さんが決めた人と結婚して家を守りなさいと
この人はもう嫌なんですね
この決めた人と結婚するの
だから私はなんで嫌いな人と結婚しなくちゃいけないんですか？お母さん
私のこと大事じゃないんですか？と聞いたみたいですね
いえ お前よりは家が大事ですよと
なんていうアホかと 家っていうのは潰れるものでしょうに
100年  200年伝統があったっても
そんなのは潰れるでしょうに
いろんな品物を作る技術はね
何百年もあったんだけど
現代技術でこれ消えちゃうでしょうね
この間私は YOUTUBE で見たんだけど
スリランカでこの過去の王様の時代ででも王様たちに眼鏡を作った家族がいるんですね
すごいまずい家族でしたけど
昔でしょ そこでこのガラスとかないんです
ないんだけど この石ありますね
クリスタルというこの石を切って切って
もう切っても その中からすごく選ぶんですね
全くもう このあれない
あのフローと英語で言いますけど
欠陥のない一つ選んで
それからいくらか これ普通にこの足で踏んで
あの歯車を回してもらって
それで磨くんですね 磨いたところでこの型があるんですね
石でできた あれは特別な石で
スリランカでも 1箇所でしかない
その型に入れて またもう 1日
2日  3日 ずっと水をかけながら磨く
もう 2  3ヶ月ぐらいかかるみたいんですよ
一つ作るために そこを見て
これ昔の技術なんです
もしかすると当時でもう西洋の方でメガネの文化なかったかもしれません
そこまで私調べてないんだけど
そこでその人の悩みはね
まあ子供は一人いるんだけど
それは学校に行って別なこと勉強して興味ないんだと
だから私でこの伝統はすべて終わりだと
考えてみればものすごい立派な技術なんですが
今役に立たんでしょ 私はそれを見ながら
それでもあの強度が精密じゃないでしょうにと
例えば型に入れて眼鏡のあのカーブを作る
でもあの型もいくらなんでもどんどん減っちゃうでしょ
なので眼鏡かけて見えるようになったんだけど
今我々使っている眼鏡のように精密に作ったものじゃないんで
今なんのことない さっさとプラスチックでさっとはい
OK やと終わっちゃうんですね
だからいくらびっくりする技術でももう消えてしまう
余計な話になっちゃったんだけど
話戻りますけど だからお前より家が大事やと言った人がどれほどあべこべかと
自分が産んで育てた子供に対して言うんですね
だから母は母でなくなったんです
恐ろしいでしょ そんなことは
家が潰れても 財産がなくなっても
あなた方の方が大事だっていうのはね
嘘かもしれませんね 普通そうでしょ
だから普通 生命 人間持ってる心身まで狂ってしまうぐらい
この見解に固執することでなってしまう
なぜならば そのおばあちゃんがお嫁に来たとき
自分の家でもないんですよ
またお嫁に来た家なんですね
来て そこでもう奴隷みたいに家のことをやってやって
それが自分の生き方になっただけなんですね
それが自分の哲学になっちゃって
家を守ることは私の哲学やと
これがちょっと固執して逆さまになっちゃって
子供の価値まで消えてしまったんです
もうすぐ長持ちしない 5 6
年ももたない伝統を守ろうと
はい ここで人間の問題が見えてくると思います
自分の意見が正しいと固執するんです
順番にまた遡って考えてください
自分の意見正しいと言えるのかと
自分の意見には無数の生命が反論持っている
だから整理していないんです
私の意見に私が自分の投票する場合は
周りもう 100人  200人
300人反対票を出してるんですよ
だから自分が勝ってないでしょうに
なのに自分が正しいと思うところはありえない間違いなんですね
それが人間くさいんですよ
だからこれは俗世間なんです
俗世間でもそういうわけなんです
それでなんで見解が現れたのかというと
概念なんですね 概念なんで現れたのかというと
原人B出身から入った情報なんです
それはありのままに受け取ったけど
そうではないんです 勝手に合成したんです
そこからわがまま好き勝手できてきたんです
ここで今はもうひどい状態に陥っているんです
見解に固執するという
そういう順番なんです
俗世間は 知識によって心が汚れる
まあもう説明する必要ないでしょう
固執したところで愛着が生まれて
それから怒り 嫉妬 憎しみが生まれて
同じ人間に対して喧嘩を売りにいくんです
戦いに行くんです 子供が親と喧嘩するんです
夫婦は喧嘩するんです
兄弟は喧嘩するんです
憎しみ合うんです 仲良くしなくては生きていられないのに
きれいに忘れる それは潰した方が楽やと
世にありえない見解まで現れるんです
破壊主義 虚無主義などなど
ですから 知識によって心が汚れるんです
はい 智慧 真理の発見なので見解は成り立たない
したがって反論はない
まるっきり違う 智慧っていうのは真理の発見だから
意見ではないんです 私は一生でも皆様に
まあまあ聞き飽きちゃったと思いますけど
地球が丸いということは見解ではありませんね
事実ですからね ありのままのことだから
だから地球が丸いということに
反論は成り立たない そこでまたネットで聞いた冗談が漫才なんですけど
息子がお父さんに聞くんで
お父さん何？あの地球が柔道でしたっけ？柔道が格闘で曲がってるんだと言ってますけど
お父さん知ってますか？と
あのね 変なことを言うなよと
地球が曲がってるんだったら
建物あれでも曲がっていなきゃダメでしょうと
曲がってないんだからいい加減にしろよと
そしたらお父さんな わからないな
これはとかね でお父さん言う
むちゃくちゃお父さん馬鹿にするんですね
お父さんもっとバカなことを言いながらね
だったら私は曲がって立っていなくちゃあかんでしょうに
まっすぐいるんだからね
嘘を言いないよ と言ったら
あんたに誰がそんなこと教えたんで？と言ったら
学校の何々先生やというの
ああ あいつはね それ あなた方に授業するときは一杯飲んで酔っ払っていたでしょう
だから自分が曲がっていたことは
地球が曲がっていると言っただけで忘れた
忘れなさい そんな話はと
まあ漫才だからね 言ったら
でも漫才でそこで終わらないんで
だからなんて言いますか
ネタは次に来るんですね
あのねと子供に言うんですね
このみんなこの勝手に赤道とかなんとか勝手に作って
存在もしないのに そこから見たら曲がっているように
俺は勝手に地球は曲がっている
テニスボールは曲がっていると言えるんですから
地球はテニスボールのように丸いんだったら曲がっていると言えるのかい？と
私はこれって相当な理論だなと
だって考えてみれば 地球は丸いんだったら曲がっていると言えないでしょう
なんで曲がっていると
エキシスがこの角度が曲がっていると言ってるんですかね
まあそれはそれなんで
そういう冗談だから笑じる話なんですけど
まあ赤道はね 太陽がずっと当たる線を計算して作ってるんだから
赤道はね 実際しないんだけど
一応赤道のところにはちゃんと6時に太陽が消えて 6
時に日没というふうなね
位置があります その位置が中心だとすると
地球がちょっと倒れてはいるということになるんですね
どうでもいいんで どうでもいい話なんですけど
私が言いたいのは 地球が丸いということには反論はない
成り立たない なぜならば
それは調べた事実 データ
調べた結果なんですね
いわゆる真理なんですね
反論がないんです それで我々は真理を知ったところで
心は清らかで 一切の固執
観念 先入観から 離れない限り
これは現れない ちょっと間違って思いついたんです
この知恵っていうのは
心が清らかでないと怒り
嫉妬 憎しみあるとは偏見を持つことでしょう
反論に対する怒り 嫉妬
憎しみでしょう 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみを持ちつつ 知恵がつくろうとか話にならないんですね
それから固定概念 先入観
これって見解でしょ 見解には反論あるでしょ
そこから心を自由にさせない限り
知恵は現れません ということで
知識があると心が汚れる
知識にさようならと言って
知恵が現れたら心が清らかになる
皆様方は知識にさようならと言ってくださったら怖いでしょう
だって命を愛着ありすぎだから
では 地球が平らという見解がなくなっちゃって
地球が丸いというありのままの真理が人類が認めることになって
何か怖いことはある？何か困ったことがある
何もないでしょう 昔は悪霊に立たれて人は病気になる
神の怒りを買っちゃえば病気になる
神に定期的なお供えしなかったら
人が病気になる 子供を早死にするとかね
信じていたんです だから最初の医者さんたちというのはシャーマンなんですね
シャーマンで祈祷師なんですね
それ見解で その見解がなくなって
今人間はなぜ病気になるのかということは知ってるんですね
いろいろカテゴライズもしているね
ウイルス細菌の場合もあるし
寄生虫でも病気になる場合もあるし
臓器が正しく機能しない何かの原因でね
病気になる場合もあるし
食べるものによって病気になる場合もあるしとかね
で いくつかの あるいは遺伝の何かなんかトラブっちゃって
それで病気になる場合があるというふうには一応決まってはいるんです
これはデータによって引き出された結論なんで
意見ではないんです あのエイズという病気は
エイズウイルスによって起こるのだというのは意見ではないんです
インフルエンザはウイルスのせいであると
食べ物のせいではありません
それは意見ではないんですね
では 皆様方 我々みんなね
昔々持っていた見解がなくなっちゃって
今事実を知っている じゃあ損した
今 神高熱だったら 誰も神にお供えしようと走らないでしょ
子供なら病院に連れて行く
大人だったらバファリンとか何か飲んで
それで終わり 神が怒っている
すごいことになっている
何もないでしょうに かえって幸せになっているだけでしょう
かえって精神的に楽になっているだけでしょ
だから知識にさようならっていうのはそういうことなんです
知識そのものが限界になるんだから
知識そのもので心が汚れて
人間は人間に対して反対の生き方をするんだから
そういうことで 知識が
智慧が現れたところで幸福なんです
智慧によって人格が完成する
煩悩はなくなる 解脱に達する
苦しみを乗り越える 知識ではそれ何一つもできません
というわけで 知識は暗闇の方に進んでいって
人間の苦しみが増える方に進んでいて
智慧が人間の苦しみをなくす方に進んでいるんです
現代人は認めないが 私は仏教的な主観で言うならば
智慧は光を目指していく
知識は暗闇を目指して進むなんです
はい 次に学ぶ世界ということに行きましょう
俗世間も仏教も学ぶことを推薦する
しかし 両方は似ていないんです
皆様の両親もね 勉強しろ
勉強しろとずっと言っていた
お釈迦様は同じことを学びなさいよ
同じこと 似ていないんです
だからといって 頭に意見
概念 経験などを溜めることは世間的な学びです
だから世間で言うのは溜めなさい
溜めなさい 溜めなさいなんです
経験積みなさい 知識を溜めなさいなんです
ありのままに見える能力を育てることは仏教的な学びなんです
仏教 溜めなさいではなくて
ありのままに 本当のこと何かと知りたい
知りなさいなんです 溜めなさい
溜めなさいではない だから学びなさいという言葉に似ていますけど
似ていないんです とにかく溜めなさいと言われたら
だからやみくもに溜める羽目になっちゃう
だからみんなやみくもに本を読んだり
本より早いんだからといって
ページ数はたくさんで脳みそにいいからって漫画読んだり
ページたくさん分厚い本で何もデータがないんだけど
漫画の中にはね まあそういう風にとにかく溜める
何にもなってないんですね
結局は 出てこない 俗世間は欲
怒り 慢などの感情が増える学び方をします
俗世間の学問とは 欲 怒り
慢が増えるんですよ 例えば若い子がね
東大に入りたい あれ 本当に立派に勉強したいという気持ちですかね
なんかないんですかね
心の中で 傲慢とか見栄とかの欲とか
学問だけ好きだったら
私はこういう学問をやりたい
この学問については 一番トップの教授がなんだらかんだら大学にいる
だからその大学に入りますと決めなくちゃあかんでしょ
そうでもないんですね
それでお母さんに聞けば
なんで勉強しなくちゃあかんかというと
いい会社に入ってね 安定した収入を得なさい
いわゆる金儲けなさいなんです
物に執着するために 権力を握るために
物質に または存在に執着するために知識を獲得します
異論がありますか？我々はなんで勉強しますかって
物に執着するために 権力を握るために
で 物質または存在に執着するために
存在に執着することは皆様よくわからないんですね
なんで世の中で哲学があるんですかね
あれは存在に対する執着なんですね
なんで世の中に宗教というものがあるんですかね
あれって相当ややこしい学問世界でしょ
カトリック教 イスラム教というのはあまりにも単純なんですけど
ものすごい学ぶんですよ
もう大学までやっても
博士一つ二つも取ったり
いろいろ何学ぶかよくわからないんですね
あれは存在欲のためなんです
だから 皆様も哲学の本を開けて読む場合は
私は何なのか 私は偉いでしょという感じで哲学を読むんです
だから存在に執着しないと哲学も現れないんです
仏教の学ぶ世界で一切の執着を捨てます
全く正反対 仏教は執着を捨てるために学びなさいと言うんです
金儲けるためではなくて
執着を捨てるために 存在に対する執着を必ず捨てます
そこで仏教が学んで完了したら
卒塾したら 存在に対する執着も捨てるんです
ということは 知識も学問も哲学ももう要らなくなっているんです
宗教微塵も要らなくなっているんです
存在に対する執着はないんです
あなた 神様は信じていますか？と言ったら
いえ その必要はないんだよと
あんた 罪を悔い改めることは
最後の審判でやられますよと
あのね 別に罪を犯す気もないんだからね
さようなら 審判を受けるために私はそちらに行きませんからねというふうに言えるんです
心配しないでくださいと
だから 存在に対して執着さえ捨てれば
最後の審判を怯える必要もないし
パールゲートから潜って天国に行きたいというふうに期待する必要もないし
本当にその時だけ自由なんです
そこまで自由はないんです
はい 次 善悪の問題に入ります
俗世間に善悪から離れることはできません
俗世間で善悪が成り立つんです
身を守るために また怯えによって
悪から 苦労して離れることもあるが
機会があれば罪を犯します
俗世間は なんで善悪が生じるんですかね？私に見解がある
いわゆる生き方 哲学がある
私はこの私の生き方によって生きようとする
他の人々には自分の見解がある
その見解によって生きようとする
そうすると あなたの生き方が間違っている
ということになるんです
それで善悪が成り立つ
私の見解に反対をする人々は
私は間違っていると言う
例えば 私は酒 麻薬を使ってはいけないという見解を作っちゃうと
私から見れば酒 麻薬使ってる人々はみんな悪人なんですね
なぜ絶対的なイエス様ではなくて
イエホワ君を信仰しなくちゃいけない
これこそ真理であって正しいという見解が現れたら
イエホワ君を信仰しない人間がみんな悪人なんです
だから見解から善悪成り立つんですよ
そこで自分が決めた生きが生き
生き方が正しいと思っているでしょ
世間が批判すると苦労してやめます
例えば私が金が欲しくて欲しいし
しかし苦労したくないと哲学もする
金が欲しいんだけど 朝から晩まで苦労はしたくない
私の哲学 金が欲しいでしょ
すると私は人の金を取らなくちゃあかんですね
仕事をしないで 私にとってそれが正しいんです
自分の哲学だから しかし
世間は人のものを取るなよと言っているんです
訴えますよと 裁きますよ
刑務所に入れますよ と言うと
私は怖い では盗まないことにしようと決めるんです
私の哲学は違います それで機会があったらやっちゃいます
だから皆様 嘘をついてはいけませんって偉そうなこと言ったっても
あれは世間の話に乗ってるだけで
チャンスがあったら嘘をつくんです
邪な行為はあんなのはとんでもない
悪い だらしないと言ってる
悪いにチャンスがあったらやっちゃいます
俗世間は悪と感情に溺れています
これで我々生きている
この俗世間というのは
悪と感情に溺れている世界なんです
苦しみをなくす目的で苦しみを作るのは俗世間です
それ私たち俗世間もブッダと同じ
苦しみをなくしましょう
苦しみをなくしましょうと偉そうなことやってますけど
世間のこのやり方ではどんどん苦しみが増える一方です
次 聖者の学ぶ世界に入りましょう
ちょっとすごく丁寧に聞かないと
ちょっと話がなんか難しくなってるような感じがしますけどね
だからちょっと休憩でもしようかなと
まだたくさんありますから
もうちょっと進んだところで休憩します
聖者の学ぶ世界 俗世間の学問と仏弟子たちの学問は違います
これからは 相当難しくなるんです
であまり進んではないんですからね
こういうのは はい これはパーリ語の
私は怠けてパーリ語の文章をそのまま入れちゃったんですね
この引用したのはパーリ聖典の中で
今まで誰にも解説できなかった経典なんです
日本訳もあるんだけど
誰一人もそのお釈迦様がおっしゃったこの経典の意味を理解してないんです
これ 誰にも理解できないかというと
私はすごく腹が立ちまして
これで説法でもしようかなと思ったんですけど
私のやり方では これはまあ 10回ぐらい分けて講演会やらないと経典終了することはできないので
ものすごい難しいんで
何か最近テレビの説法を聞いていて
あるお坊さんが 彼の学者の坊さんですけど
この経典のほんのわずかな一行引用して説法を始めて
この経典は私にもわかりませんと
だったら説法のテーマにする必要はないんだけどね
私にもわかりませんと
でも諦めないで これからも何とかして学ぼうとしますよと
ので この経典のエピソードをたくさん喋って
それはすごい感動的で面白いんだけど
エピソードだけで説法は終わり
で あの そのお坊さんも強調したのは
お釈迦様が人間が自分の話を理解し
納得し 喜ぶことをが期待
期待ではなくて目的にして説法するんだと
だからお釈迦様の説法を聞いたら
たくさんの人々が悟りに達しますよと
この経典はあえて違いましたと
相手に理解できそう 頭が混乱しちゃって
途方に暮れる結果を考えていたんだと
なんでわからない説法をわざわざ言ったのかというと
みんな調子に乗り上がっていたんです
人たちがあまりにもシンプルで語られるんだから
で だからお釈迦様がある経典をざーっと語られたんですね
これは中部経典 中部経典の第1なんです
第1番目の経典 そこからちょびちょびっと
この経典の内容を言いませんよ
心配しないでくださいね
このアクセスポイントだけにね
そのアクセスポイントで
この学び方の差をお釈迦様はまず教えるんです
アッスとはプトゥッジャのアリアナンアダッサアビ
アッスとはプトゥッジャというのは学ぶことのない俗人が
そこで学んだことはない
俗人といったら仏教の学び方を考えているんです
世間の学びじゃないんです
アリアナンアダッサアビ
聖者と付き合うこともなく
アリアダンマサアコビド聖者が語る真理に
事柄については何も学ぶ習うことがなく
アリアダンメアビニート
訓練していない聖者の教える事柄について
それで繰り返しサップリサーナンアダッサアビ
仙人に会ったことがない
仙人が語る物事に対して学ぶ見習うことも訓練したこともないんだと
知識と知恵の差を中部教典ナンバー1で詳しく語られています
それで 例えば次のセクションはこれすごいややこしいんです
経典は だからこうやってちょっとちょっとフレーズを取るしかないんです
俗世間はパタウィンパタビトサンジャナアティ
これたった一つのサンプルなんです
パタビっていうのは地水火風の地なんですね
まあ土だと思ってください
昔の話ですからね 土を見て
あ これは土ですと概念作る
花を見たら あ これバラの花ですとすぐ決める
これはおにぎりです これは弁当です
これはケーキですとかね
見た瞬間に決めるでしょ
それなんです パタウィンパタビトサンジャサンニャットワパタビンマンニャティ
これ これは土ですと これはバラの花ですと決めてから
それについて思考する
マンニャティっていうのは考えるということで
いわゆる私がものの見方は仏教
日本の言葉があるんです
ものの 妄想する それについて
じゃあバラですねって言ったら
それから妄想してください
いくらでも世界が現れるでしょう
パテヴィアマンジャティ
バラ原因にして バラについて妄想する
あるいは土について妄想する
パタヴィとマンジャティ
バラの話にしましょう
このバラの花を持って何かできることないのかとかね
そういうふうに妄想する
パテヴィンメティマンジャティ
この土は私のものである
これ バラの花は私のものである
あるいは私のものではないとか
他人の人の花 これはあなたのバラの花
これは私のバラの花と思っちゃう
それからパテヴィンアビナンデティ
その今 土はわからないんだから
バラの花にしまったけどね
バラの花を喜ぶんですね
愛着が生まれる それで執着が生まれたんです
概念から執着が生まれるプロセスはこちらでものの見事に語られているんです
しかし テーマが難しいんです
我々のバラの花とかね
おにぎりの程度じゃなくて
地水火風やら瞑想する人々の禅定状態とかね
高次元の存在とか そういうものをテーマに入れてるんだから
ちょっと理解できなくなっているんです
タンキッセへと なぜでしょうか
アパリニャータンタッサーティワダミ
教育を受けていないからやと言いますよと
そこで教育は ブッダの世界の教育なんです
なんかすごく難しいんです
例えばブッダの世界でもペットボトルという風になるんです
これ 何がわかる？ペットボトル
しかし ペットボトルってね
面白いね もうあれそれはないんです
それについて妄想しないんです
ペットボトルという概念に執着もしないんです
ペットボトル それで終わり
それはこれ バラの花といいますよ
この花の名前はバラといいますよ
それでさようなら 本当は知ってるのは
バラの花っていろいろ種類がありまして
これはなんだらかんだらの種類のバラの花で
これはこれぐらい値段のあるもので
こういうこういうふうにこれは作られて
もうあれやこれやとかね
生ける場合はこういう風に生けた方が
これは季節的に言えばこういう季節で使うものやとか
執着むちゃくちゃでしょ
それは何もないんです
バラの花といいますよ
まあせいぜいまあ 1 まあ 1 週間ぐらいでこれもう枯れてしまいます
私のものでも あなたのものでも何でもないや
これはということは 聖者の世界の学び方なんです
ヨーピソービッカー 日本訳はしなかったんだから
口で訳しました ヨーピソービッカーウェビクアランキーナーソー
悟った人 阿羅漢になった人はウシタは修行を完了し
完了している方からに言う
見えますかね やるべきことはやり終わって
大ひたバールを荷物を下ろしている
いわゆる輪廻転生という荷物
アヌッパッダサタッタと
次の言葉 真理に達している
いわゆる悟っている パリッキーナバガサンヨージェの煩悩
すべてなくなっている
束縛をね 次 サンマダンニャヴィモッタ
正しい智慧で解脱に達している
聖者のことなんですね
はい 完全に悟った人はどうなるのかというと
そうぴ その人もパテヴィン
土はパタヴィトアビジャナ
アティ 土は土であると
ちょっとアビジャナ―ティっていうのは
ちょっとサンジャナ―ティよりレベル高いんで
よう知ってるんです これが土ですと
バラの花といったら バラの花ですったら結構知ってるんです
パテウィンパタヴィトアヴィンニャニャヤ
パタヴィンナマンニャディ
パタ 土は土だとよう知っていて
それから妄想はしない
パタヴィンナマンニャディ
で パタヴィヤーナマンニャティ
もう土についても妄想しない
土はどうしようああしようこうするも妄想しない
それからここパタヴィンメーティナマンニャティ
この土は私のものだとは思わない
いわゆるバラの花だったら
これは私のバラの花という感じは生まれませんと
パテリンナーヴィナンダンティ
あ いいんだ いいんだ これバラの花はなんていいもの
それもない それ感情はないし
理由はタンキッサヘトゥ
タンキッサ その理由は何なのか
カヤーラーガッサヴィータラーガッタ
欲がなくなったからなんです
はい それで聖者の学び
世界のこれ卒業者なんですね
前の段落であったのは一般人の世界
物事を知って知って妄想してすごい煩悩の世界を作る
知ると言ったっても もうサンニャ
まあ勝手に概念を作る
好き勝手に 眼耳鼻舌身から
ブッダの世界は眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報を勝手に組み立てることをしません
ありのままに見る だからアビジャーナティという言葉を使っているんです
はい それで聖者の世界の学び世界が違うとわかったとは思います
はい ここで休憩にいたします
まあタイトル変わりましたからね
では 次のセクションに入ります
次のテーマは聖なる世界に挑戦である
聖と俗の差を説明しました
だからポイントは俗のままでいなさいではないんだからね
聖の世界に入ってほしいんだからね
で 俗世間の人々は聖なる世間にやっぱり授戒を受けて
入らな資格を取って入らなくちゃあかんですね
要するに圏外を乗り越える訓練ですね
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
で 道は順番にできてまして
我々は今知識に頼っていますね
だから仏教の場合も あんた聖なる世界に入りたいのかと
で 今あなた知識に知識中心に生きているでしょ
だからそこから始めましょうと
だから宗教と違うところは
そこから始まる 宗教は信じなさいというところからスタートするんですね
もうどうしようもない概念
先入観でまず入れるんです
神やら魂やら永遠やらね
すべて屁理屈な概念を提案して信じなさい
はい それから始めましょうと
そういうやり方ではない
知識から始めましょうと
ちょっとそれだけ例話がありまして
聖なる学び方と智慧の世界の
いわゆる俗世間の学び方と聖なる世間の学び方が
私はすごいくだらない例えで考えたんです
例えばどこかで手打ちそばの作り方を教えてやろう
学ぶところでしょ そちらに一般人
の一人と仏弟子の聖者の一人が入る
弟子として入る 二人ともそばの打ち方わからない
そこで一般の人がそばをちゃんとみくちに打って
よくそばができるようになって大喜び
もう私にそばはもう粉から打つことはできませんよと
そば粉からもう練って
もうちょっと伸ばして
また伸ばして また伸ばして
もう綺麗にそば作れますよと
どうだいと この人は許可取ってそこで自慢するんですね
欲が生まれてるんですね
それから手作りそばをみんなに食べさせたり
まああまりひどいんだったら
店でも始まるかもしれませんね
それで聖者の場合は そばはこういうこういう風な打ち方で
そばの粉っていうのはあまり粘り気はないものだから
こういう風に練った方がよろしいし
切るときはこういう角度でこういう風に切った方が綺麗に切れるし
食べれば人間の肉体に栄養になります
あなたに私にも作れますよ
終わり だから一人の心が汚れますか？一人の心が汚れていないんです
よりしてよ 世にはいろいろ食べ物はある
ただ形が変わるだけで別な名前をつけちゃって
肌触り 歯触りが変わっただけで名前をつけちゃって
みんな様々な煩悩を作ってみる
よう見ると ただもう肉体が壊れているんだから栄養を取っているだけだと
だから壊れる分 修復の量だけ食べればいいんじゃないかっていうことで終わるんです
腕も上がってるんです
もしかすると 聖者の弟子がものすごい早く出家する可能性もあります
だってちゃんと物事をしたりするんだから
そんな感じなんです 我々は何か学ぶと欲が生まれて心が汚れる
聖者が心が汚れないために学ぶんです
はい  次のテーマにそれから入ります
知識からスタート 知識を得る時も理解能力
自ら判断が必要です 仏教の世界では
この人間持っている理解能力
それが必要です 皆様にも理解能力はある
理解能力は全くなければ学べないでしょう
だから勝手に理解するんだけど
好き勝手に でも理解能力を大事にするんです
仏教でも それで人間での好き勝手でしょ
それもお釈迦様が認めてあげる
あなたは自ら判断しなさい
世間の考えは気にする必要はない
だから誰にだってブッダの学校に入る資格はあるんです
誰にだって知識は捨ててないし
知識が得た時 自分が理解能力を持っていたんです
知識は自分の我がままを好き勝手に判断したんです
お釈迦様はそれでよろしい
理解能力と自ら判断するところから始めてくださいと教えていくんです
先入観から離れて理解する訓練するんです
それから先入観を離れることを教えるんです
一つ一つ教えてあげる
これってあのね 先入観じゃないの？とか
例えば ある  ブッダの時代での話を言うと
ある行者が裸で裸で もう体洗わないで
10年  15年間修行している
で これ体汚いだけでしょうにとお釈迦様に言われたら
と言われても 私は長い間やってきたんだから
やめたくはないんだと
それってあなたの先入観でしょ
間違っていたとわかってもやめたくはないということは
固執して自分の意見ね
先入観で生きていることでしょうということになるんです
サーリプッタモクレン尊者が入っていたサンジベルラプッティベッラティプッタというね
有名な先生のところで
もう偉大なる二人ですから
で その二人もその時その宗教を信仰していたんです
で ブッダに出会って悟り開いたらみんなに教えたんですね
あのね 先生の方で真理がないんだと
私二人が真理発見しましたよ
先生もいかがでしょうかと
一応みんな真理を探し求めていたんだから
真理を教える人のところに行きましょうと
言ったら サンジェイさんが
あのね 私はインドで有名人だと
ゴートマよりは有名だと
それから長い間この教えを教えてきたんだよと
いわゆる不覚論なんですよ
教えているのは不可知
知識は不可能であると
知ることは不可能であるという哲学者なんです
弟子がたくさんいるんだよと
では あなた言うことは真理だったらね
まあ弟子たちの中で行きたい人は行ってもいいやと
そしたらすっ飛んだ弟子たちが
じゃあ我々はこの偉大なる知識の二人のと一緒に行きますと
言ったら サーリプッタ尊者がこれはいくらなんでもかわいそうということで
半分選んで より智慧のある人々でしょうね
半分選んでお釈迦様のところに行って出家したんですよ
ですから 学ぶ世界で捨てることを学ばなくちゃあかん
時々私の話を聞いたキリスト教の方々も
でも今まで信仰したの
神様やら教会の関係とかどうしましょうかと
それはもう先入観で 今までの訓練に足が引っ張られていること
なんか勇気がないんですね
これが正しいと思ったら
とんっと捨てていかなくちゃあかん
で 正しいと思ったのに間違ってたら
また別のところに行けばいいんです
そこでいつか真理に達するんです
我々みんな失敗するのは文化で理解する
歴史を使って理解する
あるいはもう先生古いね
まあ日蓮親王が誰やこれやとかね
そういう人々の言葉に照らし合わせて理解しようとする
聖書に照らし合わせて理解しようとすると
そこで先入観なんです
自ら判断しなさいなんです
何も参考にするなよと
だから自ら判断する正しい仕方をブッダが教えるんです
何かに参考したら先入観なんです
だからこのカーラマの人々を
きっと村の人々には自ら判断しなさいとずっと教えてあげて
この学ぶ方法を参考にするなよと
聖典は神の言葉は 伝統は
歴史は 理屈は 何一つも参考にするなよと
自ら判断しなさい で あなた方に聞きますよと
あんた 欲っていいものだと
悪いものだとわかっている
うーん 私から見れば悪いものやと
では 欲に基づいて人が喋ったり
考えたり 行動したりすると
それは良い行為になる
汚れた行為になる どう思う？まあ
それは汚れた行為 になりますし
欲によって人は殺生したり
盗んだり 邪な行為をしたり
嘘をついたりすると あれは善行為？悪行為
うん 悪行為ですねって答えるんです
何も参考にしていない
自ら判断する それでお釈迦様は
ほら 見てください 貪瞋痴は悪の根源であり
貪瞋痴に基づいて殺生などなどの罪を犯すことは間違っていると
あなた自分で判断しているのではないかと
はい さようならと はい
で あーわかりましたと
だから面白いんです ブッダの教え方は
仏教は全部教えているんだけど
自分で判断しているんです
私はあなたに教えたわけじゃないんだよと
あなたは自分で発見したんだよと
だから 自分で発見するときの間違うところ
落とし穴は最初からもういわゆる先入観ですよ
現代語で言えば 様々なプレジュディス
先入観は それはちょっとごめん
やめてくださいと 何も参考にするなよと
ということで 物質 世間の思考などを学んでも良いが
生きるとは何かと学んだ方が智慧が直ちに現れます
物質の生物学を学んでもいいんですよ
ブッダのやり方で 物理学学んでもいいんだけど
大した結果はないんです
我々の見解っていうのは
私がどう生きればいいっていう問題でしょ
困っているのはそこでしょ
物理学で困ったことないでしょ？生物学で困ったことないでしょ？だから医学のね
例えば体の解剖とかね
学んだって怖いことも
私はこの間 3,000円でね
まあプログラム買いましたけど
体のいろんなところの機能
あれやこれやとあるのはね
高いなと思う インターネットで買うね
データばっかりだからね
思って ちょっと見てみようかなと思ったら
各セクションごとにまた買わなくちゃあかんですね
体の部品たくさんあるんだから
これ相当2 3万になるかもしれない
それだったら普通の印刷した本を買った方が良かったんではないかなと今悩んでいるところです
で だからこのそれも読んではちょびちょびっとダウンロードしたもの読んでみたんですけど
もう英語の本ですからね
用語は難しくて難しくて困っちゃいますけど
まあでもそれだけの話ですよ
しかし 我々は見解を作っているのは
私はどう生きるべきかということのためなんです
だったらそこは研究にした方がいいんです
どう生きればいいということは
仏教的に学ぶ それで智慧が現れます
次 心の汚れを気にする
心を汚さない あるいは汚れもなくすという目的で
聖者の世界を学ぶんです
知識を学ぶときは これで卒業して
卒業証明書をもらって
許可証を取って もう枠に入れて飾っておこうとかね
よくでしょ はない 汚れないようにと気をつけて学ばなくちゃいけない
あの仏教を学んでも ものすごく傲慢な連中いるんですよ
仏教学者が お坊さんの中で
なんか病気になるまで頭がおかしくイカれてる一人の坊主なんかにいるね
病気です あの人は大して学んでないんだけど
私こそ学んでいる人は誰もいないやとかね
貫主様にまで悪口を言うんですね
で破門されちゃったんだけど
別な宗派でまた 悪口を言ってるんで
別な宗派に入っちゃって
ですから 日常の生き方でも
心が貪瞋痴で汚れないように生き方を調整する
ブッダの世界に入って学ぼうとしたら
心汚れない学び方だから
日常生活で汚れたら困ります
ですから ご飯食べる時でも
服を着たりする時でも
できるだけ心汚れないようにと気をつけるんです
お風呂に入る時でも じゃあ心汚れないようにします
歯を磨く時も 心が汚れないようにしましょう
友達と話す時でも どこかで外食に行った時でも
じゃあ心が汚れないようにしましょうと
子供の誕生日パーティーをやるのは構わないんだけど
誕生日パーティーをやっている時でも
心は汚れないように気をつける
日常生活の中でも 汚れない心を保つようにと頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
それはわかりやすく言えば道徳
戒律ですね だから あんまり項目を気にしなくていいんです
戒律項目なくても心を心が汚れないようにと気を付ければ
もうすべて戒律オートで守られているんです
道徳がなければ智慧は現れません
そこはすごい気をつけてください
智慧っていうのは清らかな心なんです
道徳がないということは汚れたっていうことは貪瞋痴です
だから戒律を守らなくたっても瞑想して悟るぞっていうのはありえないんです
悟って煩悩が落としちゃ終わりでしょうに
ちょっと難しいんです
だから日常生活でも汚れないようにして
それで智慧が現れるんです
だから 道徳がある人に智慧がある
智慧がある人に道徳があるというふうな仏教のフレーズなんです
シーラーとパンニャー
パンニャーとシーランというブッダの言葉なんです
煩悩 執着が減るように
煩悩 執着がなくすように
現れないようにと気をつけて生きるんです
そこでお釈迦様は方法を教えています
いたって簡単ですよ 自分の心のこの汚れがなくしたいなとかね
増やしたくないなとかね
そういうふうに頑張るんです
完全に執着がなくなってしまうことを目的にする
ブッダを学ぶことで 目的が自分の心が完全に執着がない状態に作ること
ブッダの三蔵経を学んだ層はダメです
三蔵経を学びました 注釈書も学びました
全部知っている でもアウトで卒業できん
心が汚れているんだから
だから経典一つでも十分です
経典一つ学んで 頑張って実行して
心清らかな状態にしたならば卒業です
これはダンマパダでも言ってますよ
あの 心清らかにすることをしないで
仏典をすべてブッダの教えを学んだっても
もう何といいますか その
その日のその日の給料で人の牛を面倒見ていることと同じだと
インドでは牛っていうのは財産なんですよ
だから朝から晩まで牛の面倒を見て
水をあげて 餌を食べさせて
夜牛小屋に数えて入れてあげて
主人から 1 日の給料をもらって帰る
でもご主人様は牛乳やら全て財産
その人はもらっちゃいます
そんなこの...卑怯で雇われる人間なるなよと
自分の財産にしてくださいということ
まあたくさん教えがあります
はい そういうことで たくさん学んだそうは意味がないんです
心 執着をなくすことが目的なので
貪瞋痴がなくなるように
弱くなるように 感情に誘惑されないように注意して生きることが聖なる道を歩むことです
仏道で修行です 修行って言ったって簡単に解説できます
貪瞋痴が減らすようにしようかなだけなんです
感情には誘惑されませんよ
今怒ってますけど 何もしませんとかね
怒って何かしちゃうと
怒りに誘惑されたことになります
今欲が出ているんだから
何もしないで待っていることとかね
それで修行なんですよ
はい ボーダーラインで何なのかと
えーと 私見は私見は私見として見て
反対の意見もあると知る
まだまだ我々は悟ってないでしょ？聖者になってないでしょ
まだ喧嘩やるんです 見解とは私見でしょ
これは私の意見ということは
あなたにはあなたの意見当然ある
みんな個人だからね みんなそれぞれ私ですから
私には私意見あります
別に難しい 当たり前の話でしょ
私の意見がありまして
えっ あなたなんでそんな意見を持つのと
これあり得ないでしょう
これは私の意見と言った途端
相手には相手の意見がある
これは認めましょうよ
そんなに難しい？意見に執着しないで
いつでも新たなデータが入る次第
意見を調整する 見解を固定しない
現代日本人みたいなテレビで納豆食べれば美しくなるんだと言って納豆食いまくっちゃう
次の日を納豆もあまり食べ過ぎちゃうと体に危険やと
がんになるお年寄りだと納豆は絶対食べないことにするとかね
すぐ乗っちゃいますですよね
食い物と流行にも乗っちゃいますけど
見解は絶対変えませんでしょ
日本はもう 50年も経っているのに
古臭い もう成り立たない憲法やら
いろんな政治システム
経済システム 微塵も変えられないんですね
あまりにも故障しちゃって
世界がものすごく勢いで変化して
新たな時代に対応しているのに
日本だけ進化遅れてるでしょ
大変危険なんです たとえ憲法であろうとも合わない
変えましょう なんですよ
変えたったけど まず じゃあまた変えればいいんだから
この項目がちょっと じゃあ変えましょうよと
そういう風だったらいつでもベターな状況でいるでしょ
ベストでなくても だから意見というのは執着してはならない
今まだ悟ってないんだから
意見があるんです でもすぐ訂正するという態度をとる
一切は無常であると 真理であると
一切は無常であるとは真理であると理解し
納得する 悟る前に頑張ってほしいんです
無常や これも無常 あれも無常
これは無常や どう見たっても何でも無常やと
太陽は？太陽は無常 宇宙は？宇宙は無常やとかね
ブラックホールは？それは無常やとかね
私は無常やと 私の考えはそれ無常やとか
で 無常でないものは見つからないと
そういう風に世の中を見てみれば
だから無常は真理ですよ
地球が丸いというよりも真理なんです
なぜならば 地球は完全なきれいな丸じゃないんだからね
地球は自分でも動いているんです
自転公転と違って 地球も自分で収縮したり
またちょっと膨らんだりしているんです
エネルギーですからね
地球といったって 丸くないんです
本当 ただ あちらこちらからエネルギー引っ張る引っ張ると
丸いという形になるしかないんです
それでもエネルギーは引っ張り合ってるんだから
もう完璧 きれいな球にはならない
そんな話はどうでもいいですから
次に行きます そういうことで
完全完璧な真理は無常なんです
悟らなくても それぐらいは皆様に頭で智慧で発見することができます
だから 見解からどうしても腹に離れないというならば
一切は無常であるということは見解にする
相当進みますよ 因果法則を理解する
いろいろできる範囲で
これだからこうなったよとかね
これだからこうなるんだよとかね
落ち着いている 因果法則を知ると落ち着くんですよ
暖かくなってくるんだから
花が咲くでしょう で 落ち着く
それ同時に雨も降りますからね
ちょうどいい時期見てね
で あ もう早く散るでしょう
今日は一番花見には一番いい日なんですけど
ものすごく雨でいけない
だからそういうふうに因果法則で考える
落ち着いていられます
それから我々は因果法則も理解する
聖者の世界 出世間と区別
自我エゴの錯覚が消えたところで
俗世間の次元を超えているんです
今言ったのはボーダーライン
皆様も意見に執着しない
意見をいつだって変える
私の意見があるならば
あなたにも意見があると認める
新たなデータにデータが入ったら自分の意見を訂正する
それから一切は無常であると勉強して
スタディをしてみる 物事の因果関係を理解しようとする
まだ悟ってない ボーダーラインです
心はそれなりに明らかになろうなろうとしているんです
これでボーダーラインを飛ぶということは
自我エゴの錯覚が消えたら
もうボーダーラインを越えて越して聖者の世界です
真理を発見して 心から一切の疑いがなくなって
曖昧 優柔不断などが消え
落ち着くんです 正世界では一切優柔不断はない
何の疑もない 真理知ってるんだから
異論ない 徹底した落ち着きなんです
揺らぎは一切ない 心にこの改革が起きたら
ブッダで聖者なのです
だから ああいう風にスタディする
スタディしていくと いつか心が改革を起こすんです
改革を起こしたら 聖者の世界
スタディしている間はボーダーラインにいるんです
正のボーダーラインにいるんです
だから中途半端ですよ
俗人でもないし 聖者でもないし
まあそれが正しいんですよ
汚れた汚い醜い俗人の世界にいるよりは
ボーダーラインにいた方がいい
それは正しい道なんです
怒りと欲が減ったところで
二番目のステージの聖者になります
で 自我の錯覚が消えたら聖者なんですけど
まだ昇格しなくちゃあかんですね
まだまだなんか罪にならないんだけど
機嫌が悪くなる 欲もちょこちょこある
それはものすごく減らしたら
番目の聖者に昇格する
怒りと欲が完全になくなったら
3番目の聖者になります
怒りと欲というのは存在に関わるものなんです
私はずっと説明してきたでしょ
存在欲が脳にあるんだと
存在欲があるんだから恐怖感もあるんだ
それ 怒りと欲なんですね
存在欲に関わるもの 存在欲に関わる怒りと消えたら
第3番目の聖者なんですね
この世には戻ることはない
もう存在にほぼさようならです
自分という実感さえも成り立たないと発見し
無明は完全に砕いて智慧を完成したら
4番目の最終ステージの聖者です
さらに頑張って 欲と怒りはないんだけど
なんか存在だけ引っかかっているんです
生きてるんだというね
これもなくす 無明を完全に砕く
それで 4番目の聖者になる
で 終わり 阿羅漢と言うんですね
これでボーダーラインから飛んだところなんですね
はい 次 聖なる世界の内容
ダサイメビッケダンマエーカンタニッビダーイ
ヴィラーガーヤ ニローダーイ
ウパサーマイ アヴィンヤーイ
サンボーダーイ ニッバーナアイ
サンガッタンティ 項目は 10ありますよ
比丘たちを エーカンタニッビダーイ
確実に安穏に導く ヴィラーガーヤ
欲欲から離れることにしてくれる
ニローダーイ 寂滅にしてくれる
心がウパサーマイ 心は安穏にしてくれる
アヴィンヤーイ 超一流の知恵が現れてくれる
サンボーダーイ 知恵が現れる
ニッバーナヤー 涅槃に解脱に達する項目
これ必ず達する 必ず達する項目は 10ありますよと
それはナーンヤトラスガタヴィナーヤ
ニャーンヤトラスガタヴィナーヤという言葉
スガタヴィナーヤ この 10項目は仏道でしかありませんと
よくよく見てください
聖なる世界は仏道以外は存在しないんです
本当に真面目に考えたら存在しないんですよ
完全に執着捨てることは誰も教えてないんだからね
みんな執着を教えてるんです
宗教であっても執着を教えているんです
この世に執着しないで
天国に執着しなさいと
勝手に出す この 10項目は何なのかと
で これからはおそらく日本訳は入れたと思いますから
次に行きます ブッダの教えにしか見られない
必ず離欲 安穏 寂静 解脱
涅槃に導く 10の事柄があります
この 10の事柄は正見
正思惟 正語 正業 正精進
正念 正定 正慧 正解脱です
あの八正道に 2つつなげてあるだけです
あの 9番目はサンマーンヤーナと言います
10番目はサンマーヴィムッティと言います
サンマーディッティ サンマーサンカッパ
サンマーワーチャー サンマークンマント
サンマアージーヴァ サンマーワーヤーマ
サンマーサティ サンマーサマーディ
サンマーンヤーナ サンマーヴィムッティ
まああの仏教ではあまりこの10項目はあまり聞かれ聞いてこないんですね
八正道ですね よく聞いているのは
私も考えれば お釈迦様八正道とで言ったんだからおっしゃったんだから
正道十分なんです 八正道を歩むと
正へと正解脱になるんです
だから道と結果を一緒にする必要はないんですね 10
項目になってくると 道と結果一緒にしているんです
しかし 世にない 確実に涅槃に達せられる
悟れます  100%確率です
この 10項目は 他に存在しないんだと
ブッダの教えにしか存在しないという場合は
全部10項目にしなくちゃいけないんです
この言葉の意味は一般論ではなく
経典で定義 経典の定義通りに理解しなくちゃいけないのです
なんでこう書いてあるの？正見といえば
俗世間で言ってる正見ではないんです
まあ称号いい言葉を喋りましょうよと言って
一般人が考える称号じゃないんです
で この各項目の定義 仏典にあります
あとで宿題で勉強してください
いくらでも本に書いてあります
八正道の話 例えば正語っていうのは
人の気に入るかっこいい言葉を喋ることではなくて
嘘は避ける 噂を避ける
二枚舌を避ける 粗悪語を避ける
無駄話を避けるなんです
この 4つなんです 正命っていうのは職業
適当な職業ではなく 自分の職業で罪を起こさないことをよく考える
ですから 殺生に関わる仕事を辞める
嘘をつかなかったら仕事にならないんだったら
その仕事を辞める 例えば
この肉を切ってパッケージに入れる
なんとか業者というんですね
精肉業者で仕事をするのは構いませんが
屠殺場は辞めてほしい
だから殺してきた肉をちゃんとさばいて分けて
パッケージに入れてシールを貼って出す
まあそれはただ荷物の整理だけで
そこでたくさん もう 1万羽ぐらい鶏が来たら
みんなペチペチと殺すところはやめたんです
ということなんです 正命っていうのは
そういう風に仏典で定義してある通りにやってほしい
正念っていうのは正しく考えることじゃないんです
気づき 今の瞬間に気づくことなんです
というわけで 八正道は一般人にも理解できるように
一般人にも自分の勝手な解説で実行できるように優しく説かれたんだけど
本当の意味はそうじゃないんです
聖者の意味は 一般人が自分なりに理解して自分勝手で実行しても
ブッダの教えが完全だから良い道になります
しかし 次元を破って聖なる世界で聖なる世界に入るだければ
仏典の定義に従わなくちゃいけないんです
えーと この項目はアリアマッガ聖なる道とも言います
聖なる道 ということで
彼岸と彼岸と彼岸という言葉が現れてきます
これ訳はないみたい 訳は省略してあります
キンヌコボーゴーともオリマンティーランキンパーリマンティーランという一行を見ます
釈尊 小願って何？非願って何？と聞くんです
しがん  え？ しがん  非願
え？ しがん 非願です しがんと非願
しがん？ しがんと非願
と非願  いや し  あ し しがん
しがんと非願 私のパソコンでこうで出てくるんだから
この漢字が だから小願と思っちゃったんだ
是願と非願ですね 二行目
パーナティパトーコーブラートマオーリマンティーラン
パーナティパターヴェーラマニパーリマンティーラン
という二行目と三行目の一部
殺生すること バラモンよ
このバラモンに言ってるんで
バラモンよ 殺生することはしがんである
パーナティパーターヴェーラマニ
殺生から離れること 不殺生は非願である
アディンナーダーナンコーブラームナオーリマンティーラン
三行目ですね 与えていないものを取ることがバラモンよ
しがんである アディンナーダーナヴェーラマニパーリマンティーラン
与え 不痴とは非願である
それからジャインですね
ジャインはしがん ジャインから離れることは非願
それから嘘 それからまあ知ってますね
ムサワーダ それからピスナーワーチャ
二枚舌 それからんと粗悪語
それから無駄話 それから異常欲
異常怒りと邪見 それはしがんで離れることは非願で
これでもお釈迦様がボーダーラインを教えているんです
いわゆる十悪で生きているならば
しがんにいる人間 十悪をやめて十善を行おうとするならば
非願を目指して頑張っている人々です
殺生盗み邪淫嘘まあ嘘粗悪語
邪見はしがんです 不殺生云々正見までは非願です
サマーディッキに達することは聖なる世界に入ることになるのです
とにかくこの八正道の第一
正見 見解をやめて正見になる
頑張っちゃう それでもう聖者の世界に聖なる世界に入ります
サマーディッキさえ現れたら
非願の人です 智慧とは何？サマーディッキとは何？というタイトルに入ります
なぜならば もう結論出しました
聖と俗の境目は見解があるか
正見があるかなんです
見解は俗世間にある ややこしい世界
苦しみが増える世界 正見は落ち着く世界
わかった世界 疑がない世界
だから我々は正見を学べばいいんです
というわけで 正見って何っていうことは疑問に出てくるんです
サマーディッキサマーディッキーティバンテーブッダティキッターワターヌコーバンテーサマーディッキホーティーティ
正見正見と言われています
尊師正見とは何でしょうか
と聞かれてますね お釈迦様に
ガクンと これがら難しい
ドエニッシトーカーヤンカッチャーナローコーイエーブイエーナアッティタンチェーヴァナッティタンチェ
カッチャーナ これお坊さんの名前です
あるとないという二つの極端に世間がはめられています
我々の知識はあるかないか
あるかないかで判断するんです
はめられているんです
存在する 存在しない その二つにやられているんだと
ロープサモディアンコーカッチャーナヤターブータンサッマッパニャイパッソトーヤーローケナッティターサーンホーティ
カッチャーナカッチャーナ
この世をこのこの世の正気をありのままに正しい智慧で見るならば
この世に対する無という極端がなくなる
世は現れて現れて現れてくるんですね
それを見たら 世はいないという
ないというね 極端が消える
この yes かノーかどちらでしょう
我々の心が   ローカニローダンコカッチャーナヤタブータンサマッパンニャパッサトーヤーローキアティターサナホーティ
この世この世の滅を ありのままに正しい智慧で見るならば
この世に対するあるという極端がなくなる
転転は言いました はい
これで 俗世間の人間の頭っていうのは
物事を見る時は この五感で物事を見る時はあるかないか
あるかないかという尺度で区別するんです
お釈迦様それはどちらも極端で間違いだよと
もうちょっと観察しなさいと
あるんだあるんだでは言い張っても
よう見ると消えていること見えない
だから消えていること見えちゃったらあると言えないでしょう
世の中ないない こんなものは幻覚だ
嘘や幻だ そんなこと言ったって
世の中現れてくるのは見えるでしょ
そうするとないという極端も消えますよと
ウパーユパーダーナビニウェーサービニバンドークワヤンカッチャーナローコーイエーヴィエーナ
カッチャーナ この世はほとんど見解に執着して見解に見解を追い求めているんです
それであるという見解
ないという見解 天国がある
ない そこばっかり探しているんですね
神がいる いない そこで追い求めているんですね
それでいると思う人はいるということに執着する
神がいないという人は
それに執着する タンチャーヤンウパーユパーダーナン
チェータソーアディッターナンアビニウェーサーヌセーアナン
ナウペーティナウパーディエティ
ナーディッターティアッターネーティ
これは難しいんだから
ちょっと飛ばします あらゆる見解に執着してはならない
これは我である 私であると思ってはならない
みんなやっていることをやってはいけないと言っているんです
見解を作って それに執着して
やがて見解が自分になってしまっちゃうんですね
これが私ですと おそらくこれ
ウパニシャッド哲学に対してお釈迦様の反論でもあり
哲学者たちはあれが私です
あれも私です これも私ですというふうに哲学するんです
妄想の達人たちなんです
でも インドではすごい優れた哲学だと思っているんですが
誰も信仰はしていないんです
破壊の神シヴァ神ばっかり信仰しているんです
ドゥッカッメーワウッパッジョマーナンウッパッジョティドゥッカムニルッジョマーナンニルッジョティーティ
ナカンカティナヴィチキッチャティアパラッパッチャーニャーナメーワッサエッタホーティエッターターコカッチャーナサッマーディッティホーティ
エロケッスル ショーキスルナ
も滅するのも苦であると
苦が生じて苦が滅する
自分で体験して発見することで
疑を乗り越えた揺らがない智慧が現れます
それが正見です それは聖者の世界です
説明することはできません
もうかなり内容は厚すぎ
で 世の中ありのままに見ると
物事は現象は現れてくる
この現れてくる現象は苦なんです
世の中を観察すると現象は消えていく
消えていくものも苦なんです
だから苦が現れて苦が消えているんだと理解しなくちゃいけない
頭で理解じゃなくて 調べて調べて調べまくって
研究して研究して研究しまくって
自分の体で体験するんです
そうすると あ これが真理やと疑が晴れてしまいます
揺らがない智慧が現れます
それに正見と言います
だから正見が現れたらもう聖者です
それから あるなしの極端を避けて
中正中小の真理を語られる
同じ経典でお釈迦様が
それからあるとも言わない
ないとも言わない真理を語っていくんです
それはこれがあるから
これが起こるなどの因果法則の説法です
だから因果法則とは あるともない
ないともない因縁でよりますよという話ですね
四聖諦 因縁 無常 苦 無我を知ることは智慧であります
はい 智慧っていうのは頭がいいわけじゃなくて
四聖諦を発見すること
因縁を発見すること 無常
苦 無我を発見することが智慧です
発見する人は聖です 聖なる人です
で 集約しましょう 心が実体論で働く間は俗世間です
我々の心は実体論で物があるに決まっているんだと
こちらバラの花があるに決まっているんだという態度で生きているんです
決まっていない 因果法則でバラの花があるんだという幻覚が生まれるだけなんです
この幻想が因果生まれた因縁があるんです
だからバラが実際するという証明はないんです
はい そういうことで 実体論に引っかかっている間は俗世間です
実体論が完全に消えて
現象は因縁によって一時的に現れて消えるものだと発見したところで
聖なる世界です この目的を目指して努力する人は道の人です
いわゆるボーダーラインにいる人です
ボーダーラインとは未知の人のことです
そんなことで 今日の話はちょっと難しかったかもしれませんだけど
終了いたします どうもありがとうございます
先ほど歯磨きをするときにも
歯磨きをするときにも
口の汚れを汚れないようにするっておっしゃいました
具体的な方法を教えてください
だから ちゃんと歯磨きをして一生歯を守らなくちゃあかんやとかね
綺麗な白い歯でかっこよくつけようと思ったら汚れてるでしょ
あー私の歯が綺麗になっちゃった
さっぱりやと思ったのに
汚れでしょ そうではなくて
歯は汚れるんだ 磨いても汚れるんだ
汚れたらすごく不浄で私にも気持ち悪いんだ
しかし これ汚れ 汚れを落として清潔に保たなくちゃいかんが
これはもう終わらない作業やという感じの
ありのままに観察しながら歯を磨く
最低 勝手にこれは汚れて臭くなるもんだなと思いつつ歯磨いたっても
まあ心は汚れないんですね
虫歯にならんように まあ健康のためにやるとやっちゃうと汚れてるんです
だから ちょっと無常の方に
不浄感の方に心が持っていけば
で 心は綺麗に保てるんです
以上です  あと まだ大丈夫です
質問ある方いらっしゃいますでしょうか
先ほど憲法もどんどんベターな状態にした方がいいとおっしゃいまして
で 現在 あの平和憲法とか
そちらの方が変えられようとしていますが
それについてはどう思われますか？ それはね
改革するところを改悪するのはね
正しいかどうか 国民の問題です
私は私の個人的な意見は平和条約9番ね
あれは世界どこにもないことだから
ものすごい誇りに思うべきものだと思いますけどね
でも私に関係ないしね
だから個人的な主観だけ言うと
今は憲法を改良ではなくて改悪しようとしているのではないかなと
だから日本の方々は憲法を触るなよと言っているんですね
私はそちらにも反対ですね
古い憲法は現代もっとより生き生きするために
世界でいつでももううまくね
経済的な豊かさなければみんな壊れちゃうでしょうに
だから経済は競争ですから
仕方がないでしょうに
だからこの競争の世界で生存するために
生き延びるために必要なように
人間の幸福と豊かさ 平和を考えて改良していかなくちゃいけないんですね
アメリカも怖がる中国に対してもう思い知らせてやるぞというのはね
もうどうかなってます
頭は 以上です  はい 他に質問ございますでしょうか
私の方でいいですか はい
はい どうもありがとうございます
今日のアリアサッチャーとかアリアなんとか
非常に地球上から比べると少数意見
非常に得難いものだと思います
ところが 仏教で人間に生まれるのは非常に生まれ変わるということはとても大変なことだと
砂場で海岸で砂を 1個拾って投げてくるくる回って目隠しをして
それでどこに投げた その砂を見つけるか
それぐらい難しいことだということを以前読んだことがあります
今 地球の人口は 75億です
このアリアサッチャーというものが非常に難しい
難しいというか 触れ難い俗世間にあるのかで
なぜこんな人間がどんどん増えていくんでしょうか
それは生命の数というのは
私は全体を知りませんけれども
人間がやはりお釈迦様の時代よりも 75億人という地球が垂れつつ
どんどんますます増えていくという
その得難い人間がなぜこんなに増えていくのか
ちょっとそこが私の知識ではわからない
はいはい あのね 人間って増えてないんですよ
あの それ我々東部数字で考えることだけなんですね
そんなに増えてないんです
で 増えたと感じているのは
昔の人が一生使った資源より 40倍ぐらい
今一人人間食いまくっていることなんです
ですね だから人口が増えて困るとかね
昔ね このこんなに人が少なかったっていうこともないんですね
だからそれはあんまりよく我々は歴史的にわからないことで
仏教的に言えば増えてないという態度を取ってるんですね
人間が自然を大事にして
小欲で自足できるならば
もうむちゃくちゃ人間がいた方がいいというスタンスなんです
仏教ではね 問題は一人の人間を育てるために莫大な金
金で言えば億単位でかかっちゃう
資源でしょ 食いまくっているの
地球には資源が決まってるんだから
人口が増えることは大きな問題にしている
だから結局はもう暗闇に行ってるんですね
だから科学進歩するならば
農業は進歩するならば
よりたくさん人間がいた方がいいに決まってるでしょうに
人間がいたら経済状況でしょ
なんで人間が多すぎ これで経済が崩れるって
俺えりこそでしょ だから日本の社会も子供を作らなかったでしょ
今崩れかけてるんでしょうに
だから金かかっても若者はたくさんいた方がそれが豊かであると仏教的な評価なんです
家に子供がもう 6人いるんだと
もう服はもうそんなに格好もよくて
ボロボロで汚れたり 破れたりとか
私はそれってなんて幸せだなと思いますよ
だって資源はできるだけ節約しているんだから
その場合は そういうことだから
仏教から見るとどちらかというと増やせなんです
言ってないんだけど そういう風に
仏教の経典はちょっとちょこちょこと行間を読むと
増やせなんです それで人間が死んで人間に生まれるわけじゃないんです
人間界に入る資格のある生命っていうのは
数えられないぐらいものすごいたくさんいるんです
だから人間の母体に入りたいと 100 万人ぐらい生命が
まあ私でも一人にしかチャンスがないんです
ですから 生まれるチャンスがあれば
さっと人口は増えます
それは全体的に宇宙的に考えれば
全体性的的な生命で考えれば
増えることも減ることもないんだそうです
はい  そろそろ時間なんですけど
もう 1方ぐらいかなと思います
はい じゃあ今回します
この前 小学校 6年生の女の子から質問を受けまして
先生 死んだらどうなるの？ 死ぬのが怖いと言われたんですけども
それを 3 分間で先生がどう答えますか？死んだらどうなるの？死ぬのが怖いに対してどう答えられますか？ 私は
まず その子はちっちゃな子でしたから
なんか過去のことを思い出していたんですね
だから それは皆様にちょっと使えないと思います
私の答えは なぜならば
特に子供が質問する場合は
周りのことを考えて質問する場合もあるし
漫画を見てそこから感情が出てきて質問する場合もあるし
何のこともなく過去の経験で質問する場合もあるんですね
だからそれは区別して答えなくちゃいけないんですね
だから答えられる これから答えを言いますけど
役立たないと思います
私はあの子に聞いたのは
君 死んだことある？死ぬのは怖いと言っていたんだから
君 死んだことある？って言ったら
ありますと答えを なんで小学生が死んだことある？と言ったら
皆様だったらどう思う？お前変なことを言うなよでしょ
そうじゃなくて そうでしょ？そうでしょ
あんたは死んだことがある
しかし 今まだ生きている
だから別にどうってことないでしょ
今生きているんだから
特別に怖がる必要はないんだと
一回だけじゃなくて たくさん我々は死んだことあります
死んで生まれちゃったよと
生まれたらそれを忘れちゃいますよと
忘れない方がいいやと
うん わかった 終わり だから
だから死んだことあると
あんた変なことを言うなよとかね
だから私はすごく感じたのは
あの子はやっぱり何かしら思い出しちゃったんですね
自分が死んだことを その時怖かったことも
それを呟いていたんですね
それをおばあちゃんが聞いてね
私のところに連れて行って
それでまあ 1 分以内で完了
だから解決 はい ありがとうございます
はい はい あと 5分ぐらいですね
あとお一人ぐらいで大丈夫です
じゃあそちらの女性の方最後に
今日はありがとうございました
私はなんとか一生懸命頑張って自分のことを見るように
自分と なんていうんでしょうか
心の内を見るように頑張っているんですけれども
子供が 10歳の女の子がいまして
やはり自分を見ているうちに
その子供のこともやっぱり心配になって
子供も見てしまうんですよね
で 子供の欠点を正すようなことをどうしてもしてしまって
自分を正そうと思うのと同時に
その子供も多分自分の執着がきっとあるんだと思うんですけれども
自分と一緒にこう なんだろうな
なんというか こう強引に
だからこう正そうとしちゃうんですよね
こう なんて言うんだろうな
傲慢という なんて言うんだろう
うーん やっぱり感情的になってすごく怒ってしまったり
イライラしてしまったり
で その子もやっぱり子供なので
私の気に入ることはしませんので
やっぱり私はいつでも不機嫌になってしまうというか
その子の態度をどうしてもこう直そう
直そうと やっぱり今日お話しされたような感じで
自分のこう なんかこう
グーっていう こう なんだろうな
こうすごい強い やっぱり我っていうのをすごく感じて
今すごく大変なんですが
うーん これもやっぱりしつけとかっていう風に思ってしまって
なんかこうやってるのもあるし
自分のこう 強引さにどうしてもなって
自分はもう傲慢なんだろうっていうのも感じながら
それでもこう言ってしまう自分が
なんというか こうすごく落ち込むというか
なんて難しいなっていう思いがとてもあるんですけれども
うん まあ難しいと思いますね
自分の子供だからね どうしても愛着があるし
他人の子供だったらもう帰ってくださいと言えば必ず帰りますからね
自分の子供だから一生自分がかかっているしね
だから無視しようかなと思っても
これもちょっとやばいしね
しつこく言おうかなと言って聞いてくれないしね
だから一応その状況は難しいとは思いますけど
まあ頑張るしかないんですね
頑張るっていうのは だからそちらおっしゃった通りに自分の心を見よう見ようとしているんだけど
汚さない 汚さないことをやってないんですね
心は自我のままで汚れたままでっていうことはあるんですね
だからもうちょっと進まなくちゃあかんですね
問題は子供にあるんじゃなくて
自分にあるんだと だから汚れたことは持ちませんと
心が汚れたら絶対子供にはしゃべれませんと
子供でしゃべるならば
いつでもニコニコと気持ちでしゃべりますと自分を戒めなくちゃあかんですね
ですね 子供のしつけは後回しにしてください
親たちがそう思うだけで
そんな悪くないんですよ
子供はものすごい悪いような感じであっても
社会に出たらすごい真面目にこう
行動する ですから でも親にそれ見られませんね
ある子供グループがいて
すごいやんちゃで もうお母さんにとってはもう倒れるぐらい苦労するんですね
まあいいお母さんでしたけど
いろいろ冗談で いろんなからくりで子供のしつけしてますけど
ことを聞いてくれない
それのやんちゃなことやって大騒ぎしたり
大変で それである時間私と一緒にいたんですね
この極端の悪い悪いことやってる子供たちがね
私といる間はものすごい静かで
それぞれ自分たちがやりたいことをちゃんとやって
それまた行儀よく それで私も私に何の邪魔もなく
私も本を読んでいるんですね
それで子供 お母さんが顔を真っ赤にして
さっさと部屋に子供を言ったら
私は子供にわからないように英語で聞いたんですね
あなたにできますかね？こういう風に静かにすることは
と言ったら じゃあもう私は無理で
だから学んでくださいよと
だから このそこで私が何を言いたかったかというと
そんな心配しなくていい
子供はもう社会に入ったらちゃんと大人しくやってくれます
でも母親にそれ見えないんですよ
いくらおとなしく行儀よくみんなで仲良くいるところにでも
お母さんがやったら途端
逆にわがままをやりたい放題なんですね
だからおとなしくすごいかっこよく行動する我が子は見られないんですね
母親に どうしましょうかね
だから学校の先生とかね
友達とかね 子供に対していう評価があったらそこを聞いてください
外の人はいい子ですよと言ったらいい子です
心配するしかないんです
でも家ではちょっと違いますけどとかね
言ってもいいんだけど
いい子でしたと でも家では全く鬼ですけどとかね
そういうふうにやっぱそこを解決しますよ
だからまずはお母さんの問題なんで
お母さんが汚れた心は持ちません
汚れた心で私は自己破壊するんだと
私自身が破壊すると 私は命を預かってるんだから
一人じゃないんだから
周りも破壊するんだということで
怒ってわがままで一言葉も喋りませんとしっかり決めておいてください
しつけしなくちゃいかんだけど
その時はニコニコとお母さんならそんなことはしませんだけど
まあ頭の悪い子はしょうがないなとか
そんな感じでね まあ話はわからない子はわからないねとかね
普通はやり方はこのやり方ですけどということで
なんとなく言えばいいんです
本当にわからないばね
これはね こういうふうにこういうふうにするんだよとかね
というふうに その時に全くわからないことを教えなくちゃいけない時は
そこを優しくて優しく
正しいことだよ それだけああいう風に
なんとなく軽々しく 楽しくニコニコと言えば結構聞くと思います
まず自分で頑張ってください
ありがとうございました
はい それではこれで講演会を終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッブイ キロリ ワジャンツー サムボルー ボヘナッサトゥ マテー モホッタンタラーヨ スティーディ ガヤコー モホヤ
ボート サッバ マングララン ラッカンドゥ サッバ デバタ サッバ ブンターヌ バヴェーナ サッバ ダンマ
ーヌ バヴェーナ サッバ サンガヌ バーウェナ
サダー スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダン シディ リッサー ニッチャン ワッダー パチャノー
チャッターロー ダンマー ワッダンティーヤー イワンノー スカン バラン アーユラーローゲ サンパッティ サッバ
サンパッティ メー ワチェ アットー ニッバーナ サンパッティ イミナーテ サミン ジョトゥ
サーリ サーリ サーリ  では
どうもありがとうございます